you talk about machine learning is
essentially learning by association or
reasoning by association and this do
calculus is allowing for intervention I
like that word action so you also talk
about counterfactuals yeah and trying to
sort of understand the difference in
counterfactuals and intervention
what's the well first of all what is
counterfactuals and why are they useful
well why are they especially useful as
opposed to just reasoning what what
effect actions have what kind of factual
contains what we normally call
explanations can't give an example if
tell you that acting one way affects
something I didn't explain anything yet
but if I if I ask you was it the
aspirant that kill my headache I'm
asking for foundation what kill my
headache I'm putting a finger on aspirin
[Music]
provided finish it was aspirin
it was responsible for your headaches
going away if you didn't take the
husband you would still have a headache
so Bice by saying if I didn't take
aspirin I would have a headache you're
there by saying the aspirin is the thing
that removes the headache yes but you
have to have another important
information I took the aspirin and my
headache is gone it's very important
information now i'm reasoning backward
and I said what did the Aspen yeah by
considering what would have happened if
everything else is the same but I didn't
take aspirin so you know thanks took
place you know Joe kid Schmo and Schmo
would would be alive had John not use
his gun okay so that is the
counterfactual it kinetic infliction has
a conflict here or clash between
observed facts
but he did shoot and the hypothetical
predicate which says head he not shot
you have a clash in logical clash they
cannot exist together
that's the counterfactual and that is
the source of our explanation of the
give responsibility regret and free will
yes it certainly seems that's the
highest level of reasoning right yeah do
it all the time
who does it author physicist physicist
in every equation of physics let's say
you have a Hookes law and you put one
kilogram on the spring and the spring is
1 meter and you say head this weight
beam 2 kilogram the spring would have
big twice as long it's no problem in for
physicists to say that except that
mathematics is only the is in the form
of equation ok equating the weight
proportionality constant in the length
of the string so you don't have the
asymmetry in the equation of physics
although every physicist thinks
counterfactually ask the high school
kids had the weight being three
kilograms what will be the length of the
spring I can answer it immediately
because we do the counterfactual
processing in their mind and then they
put it into equation algebra equation
and they solve it but a robot cannot do
that how do you make a robot learn these
relationships why you would learn tell
him can you do it before you go learning
yeah yeah ask yourself suppose I give
him all the information Kendall can the
robot perform a task and I ask him to
perform can he recently say no it wasn't
the aspirin it was the good news you
received on the phone
right because well unless the robot had
a model a causal model of the world I'm
sorry I've to linger on this that's now
we have to link you know we have to say
how do we do it how do we build yes how
do we build a causal model without a
team of human expert running around why
don't you go to learning right away
you're too much involved with learning
because I like babies babies learn fast
and if I got far they doing good so yeah
that's another question how do the
babies come out with the counterfactual
model of the world and babies do that
yeah they know how to play with the in
the crib they know which balls hits
another one and but they realized by
playful manipulation of the world yes
the simple world involve only toys and
balls and chimes methods every if you
see where it's a complex world we take
for granted yeah how come kids do it by
playful manipulation Plus parents
guidance pure wisdom and you say they
meet each other can they say you
shouldn't have taken my toy right but
and they these multiple sources of
information they're able to integrate so
the challenge is about how to integrate
how to form these causal relationship
from different sources of data correct
so how how much is information is it to
play how much causal information is
required to be able to play in the crib
with different objects I don't know I
haven't experimented with okay not a
crib manipulating physical objects on
this very opening the pages of a book
all the tasks the physical manipulation
tasks do you have a sense because my
sense is the world is extremely
complicated it's super complicated I
agree and I don't know how to organize
it because I've been spoiled by easy
problems such as cancer and death first
we have to start not easy there is in
the sense that you have only 20
variables and they're just variables are
not mechanics it's easy you just put
them on the graph and they they speak to
you yeah and you you're providing a
methodology for for having them speak
yeah working only in the abstract they
have to knowledge in knowledge out data
in between
you